now after a successful pilot last year
the TV show embarrassing pets is back
following a team of vet and behavioral
experts who try to fix embarrassing pet
problems and guess what we've got one
here yes an embarrassing pet although
he's no longer embarrassing I don't
think she's no longer embarrassing one
of the vets from the show Deepti
charmers here along with Tom and his
chihuahua Darcy they both feature in the
program because of Darcy's bad breath
because of Darcy's bad braxton for you
I thought all dogs had bad breath well
Darcy's was was pretty vile that's a
reef air yeah it was beyond bad it was
horrendous and so you wanted to get that
fixed and Deepti yeah so you identify
the problem and then in Darcy's case
what was the treatment so with every dog
like you said they always have a degree
of bad breath Darcy's in particular was
was quite terrible and and there's lots
of different reasons why that can be so
there can be two problems there can be
gum problems and but I'm not going to
tell you exactly how just how bad was it
Tom it and when did you think I need
help with this this is beyond normal
just the answer social part of it you
know when you've got friends come around
and family and you know she's she's
quite a cute dog I mean some people
wouldn't say that she's quite ugly but a
lot of people want to give her a lot of
thought and and when she gets close to
people it was really really really bad
and then that makes it like quite
awkward and they don't want to be around
and I just thought oh she's clearly very
sweet very cute how close did you have
to be in order to smell the badness not
not very close to be fair it was it was
really really poignant and we can smell
it from this ya know what it's resolved
Oh see have you sorted out your problems
that can't smell anything at all and
what are some of the other problems that
the pets have had without sort of giving
away too much that you've come across
there's lots of interesting cases on the
show and there's such a big variety we
know we've got parrots over had jugs I
think with your hedgehogs yeah so that
was a very interesting case I had as
well
we're one of the head jobs would only
ever eat chicken nuggets and nothing
else so hey there's really lots of
interesting cases on there I didn't even
know hedgehogs ain't meat
we just gave them milk and bread no
that's that's what you shouldn't do
isn't it and Tom what was it like for
you and Darcy taking part in in the
program it was really really positive
really great experience it was really
good to see obviously the other pets and
what what what other people face what
other problems people face but it was
just a really positive experience to get
Darcy's breath sorted because what I
thought it was it turned out to be
something completely different and how
soon after the treatment did he start to
see change immediately it was immediate
yeah obviously Darcy had a couple of
days recovery but ya know it was it was
immediate and I was thankful for that
because my my home doesn't smell a bad
breath anymore
that might seem sort of quite
superficial problem to some people were
you seeing more serious cases that
really impacted on on the families of
the other pets yeah absolutely so a
problem that's embarrassing can have a
domino effect and really change the
status of a pet at home and affect every
member of the family so my job is one of
the vets on the show was to really try
and provide a helpful solution and try
and give them some hope that actually we
can't fix things and we can really
change things at home for your pet which
is really important you surprised that
what a hit the the program has been with
this subject matter because it was an
issue just a pilot but it's been so
successful that it's it's coming back
it's a full-blown series I think as a
nation we love pets and this show in
particular it's really fun it's really
light hearted and there's just so many
different cases that it's interesting to
watch and people also learn a lot from
watching it in a fun way so I'm not
surprised I actually wouldn't expected
something like this to really engage
with the public and Tom finally tell us
how Dulce got her name I think it just
suits her she dances around about legs
like a certain ballerina so there's a
clear there yeah but now I think she
just suits the name so
what we paid